Hi everyone! My name is Tamara Chambers,
and this is "Tamara's Never Seen!"
And today, I am watching, "Cool Runnings."
This came out on the Disney Channel I believe in 1993.
Or was it just a Disney movie?
I don't really know. I could look it up.
I was only 2 years old when this came out.
I actually haven't even really heard of this film before.
Doug was like, "have you seen 'Cool Runnings?'"
"What... is that? Nope. No."
Looks like it wasn't an original Disney Channel movie.
It looks like it was just like a main...
theater release film. It really seems like it was. [laughing]
I've got my lucky egg!
I'm not gonna break, because it's not hard boiled.
I am very excited to talk about "Cool Runnings!"
Let's do it!
♪ ♪
[splat]
Okay, I absolutely loved this movie.
It started out, and it looked like it was gonna be a little dated, and a little cheesy,
and it totally was, and it was totally okay.
I think that they did a really good job of storytelling, a really good job with the characters.
I really loved the main four guys.
I was watching it alone and throughout watching it,
I would just say to myself, like, "Oh, I'm loving this!" [laughs]
This is how I always am.
I haven't looked yet if it's real or not? Like, how well they got it right.
Before the video's up, I will, I'll do some some fact-checking.
And we'll find out together. You all probably know already.
The story is about a man who wants to run track for the Olympics for Jamaica and
him and two others trip in the finals to get into the Olympics and so,
desperate to get into the Olympics, they start a bobsled team.
John Candy plays a bobsled coach,
who, in his glory days, earned two gold medals himself for bobsledding.
He just sits there and drinks Red Stripes and bets on things and plays pool in Jamaica.
Sounds like a dream life, honestly,
but I think it really works well. He's excellent in it.
The movie opens up on our lead, training for the race.
And I got my first, like, chuckle of the film before the opening credits stopped rolling.
So it was a good omen starting out.
You see him running by, and one of the ladies in his town goes,
"Handsome as a lion, that one! I could watch that backside all day!" [laughing]
It's like, yeah, nice. She knows what's up.
Sanka is great, I think he was really funny.
I loved the "Sanka are you dead?"
"Yeah, man."
Same, somehow.
Like I said, him getting into the Olympics for track gets ruined,
but then he hears about John Candy's character being there,
and goes and tries to make something of bobsledding.
I really enjoy that it's based off of a true story, and I want it to be mostly true. I'm hoping it's mostly true.
I feel like Disney is gonna crush my spirits when I find out that it's not mostly true.
I just continuously loved Sanka's character, and I loved when he found out that bobsledding was in winter,
and he's like, "As in ice? As in ice?
"Winter as in ice. As in igloos and Eskimos and penguins... that kind of ice? As in ice?"
That was me when I got to Chicago, so yeah.
Yes.
So the film has a lot of montages.
There's the montage of trying to get John Candy to coach them,
then there's a montage training them,
and then there's a montage raising money, and it's very Disney montage. Here we go!
We got to get to the actual race portion, so let's just get this stuff out of the way!
I love that they keep so positive and there's a lot of lessons being learned throughout.
They only have five thousand dollars for their sled.
Somebody gets them an old training sled, and so they get this piece of junk,
and the lead character is still so optimistic.
It's like it's beautiful and so excited just to be there and so grateful and it's just,
it's so endearing.
Also some of the lessons that they taught.
People were making fun of them for their sled, and for their outfits,
and just for never having been... be... being there [laughing]
and, and for various other things,
racist things, and...
one of them was like, "Why?"
and the tough broody one was like, "Well, we're different. People always are afraid of different."
And it was just a really quick thing. They could have really dove into that aspect of it,
if that's what happened,
they could have really dove into that but it was just like a...
"We're also dealing with this crap!" Kinda like, throw away. Like it's in there a little bit.
It was. I loved it. I loved it.
I think that the writing was...
thoughtful,and it's so cheesy, and it feels like a Disney film, but it feels...
I don't know, "genuine", still.
There's also a moment where Yul Brenner thinks that he's gonna get out of Jamaica and out of the town.
He's shaming all of them, and he's like, "I'm gonna live here",
and he pulled out a picture of the Buckingham Palace.
He doesn't know that it's the Buckingham Palace.
And they're all like, "The Queen lives there, man. Like, you're not gonna live there."
And it really breaks his spirit for a moment,
and then Junior comes over, who Yul has been picking on the whole time,
and Junior's like, "No, we need people like this, man. Find your castle."
And gives them the thing back, and I was like, crying, it was so thoughtful and sweet and cute.
Then I just put, "Oh, now we're line dancing in a cowboy bar. There's the Disney I know!"
This happens to turn into one of my favorite scenes in the whole film though.
The Germans are picking on them, because Disney always has to have a bad guy,
and in this film, it's the German team for some reason.
And they're just super rude to them because they're like, the popular bobsled team.
But Junior's like, very down on himself, and he's also facing like some things with his father
And Yul Brenner goes in and he's like, "No, man.
"No! You gotta look at yourself in the mirror, and you gotta say this back to yourself,
"I see pride, I see power, and I see a badass mother who don't take crap from nobody!"
Yes, I loved this part!
And I also love when it comes back into the end when the father comes and confronts him,
and he finally stands up for himself.
The friendship that they develop, it's like they were obviously gonna be friends,
they're the bobsled team, so they start off as enemies, they become friends.
It's very Disney, but it's just... it really made me happy. [laughing]
It really worked well!
Then we get a very Disney cowboy bar fight.
Another... like, it's just good feeling after good feeling after good feeling.
Even in the end, when it's not a good feeling, it's a great feeling.
They qualify for the finals, and then you see the three different races,
and they do terrible, and then do great, and then they're doing really great, and then their
terrible $5,000 bobsled falls apart, and they pick it up and then carry it across, and it was so good.
I imagine that part is real.
That's what inspired the film is that this Jamaican bobsled team, unlikely,
makes it to the finals. It's in the Olympics, their thing falls apart, and then they carry it across.
I imagine if there's any truth to this, it's that.
The bad guys become respectful friends, the Germans,
and Junior's father is there, wearing a Jamaican shirt, cheering them on.
And they make it to the finish line.
John Candy feels a sense of pride for having done something good,
somehow redeeming himself for cheating all those years ago.
Gets wrapped up very abruptly, and it wrapped up super Disney,
But I loved it! It was so feel-good! I love feel-good movies!
Oh my, I'm such a sucker for feel-good films, and this was definitely one of them.
I didn't care that it was dated. I just, I just loved it.
Lipstick on my egg.
It's a real lucky egg.
"It's a feature Disney film, not much in it actually happened in real life."
Oh, no!
"The team was recruited from the Jamaican army." They weren't track stars.
Oh, "The movie also depicts the Jamaican bobsledders as outcasts, but in real life, they were welcomed warmly at the 1988 Olympics."
Well, they didn't carry it to the finish line.
"Feel the rhythm, feel the rhyme, get on up, it's bobsled time" was made up. That's disappointing.
"You will relate so hard to the Calgary Airport scene."
Yes, Marissa.
"You will find yourself far more moved by the ending that you would expect from a 90s comedy."
Yes. I...
wasn't expecting to enjoy this as much. A lot of people said that it was gonna be dated, which it totally is, but,
for some reason it just struck a chord, and I really enjoyed it.
[laughing] "I'm not smoking, I'm breathing."
Yup! Chicago winter!
"Just prepare for a lot of Jamaican stereotypes and probably John Candy's best dramatic work."
I don't know what else I've seen John Candy in. I know that I have seen him in something else...
but I don't know what it was.
And then, yes, there were a lot of Jamaican stereotypes. It was very...
Disney Jamaica.
It wasn't, like, authentic Jamaica. It was very Disney Jamaica.
Is it great?
"You'll want to do the non-sarcastic slow clap that people do at the end of inspirational sports movies.'
The slow clap in this was so insane.
There's like hundreds of people just going like this very intensely into the camera, and it's a lot, and I loved it.
I had a blast watching this.
Thank you so much for watching this.
Next week, I'm coming at you with "Austin Powers,"
So check out "Tamara's Never Seen" next week. I'll see y'all then. Bye!
♪ ♪